[Music]
hallo Leute of just Louis and our
friends this is guns in here
welcome to the 54th episode of dirty
chess tricks in this episode I'm going
to show you a surprising and a wonderful
trick against classical English from the
black perspective the opening arises
after the following model Sifu ePHI
Knight to c3 Knight to f6 and now the
pure classical English start with g3
followed by Bishop vegeto well against
this my recommendation is you should
start with this cunning moon c6 so
planning to go defy and when white
continue with Bishop to g2 you indeed go
ahead with the Moody Phi which not only
allows you to grab space in the center
of the world
but it restrict the white activity now
if you oppor and continue with slow
moves such as Knight to f3 or d3 then
black can able to maintain his wonderful
center and space in the center of the
board which gives him already an
advantage in the opening so accordingly
as per the database the most frequent
choice from the white campus Queen to b3
which at first sight looks so
threatening as not only it attacks
thrice on D Phi Square but on the other
hand black can't even successfully
defend that pawn for example black can't
even save the pawn with either the move
Bishop to e6 or d4 he
either case he is going to lose the
vital pawn on b7 and after Bishop
captures b7 Queen captures b7 Knight to
d7 white can simply continue with Knight
to defy trying to get folk on c7 so
black has to remove this dangerous night
but the end of the sequence it is white
who emerged with an extra pawn on the
Queen side and as you can see I have
highlighted simple but effective plan of
campaign by white namely d3 Knight to f3
Castle and remain a healthy pawn up so
does it mean that black has done an
opening disaster well of course not in
fact black has set up a tricky platform
starting with might to c6 sacrificing
the most important center pawn and the
real fun begins
when white accepted now white can become
cover and decline this with the Moody
tree but in this case black and simply
consolidate his center with Bishop to e6
and now indeed Queen to b7 is a disaster
zone for the white cam as after Knight -
before we are threatening a folk and
when white get out of it let's say King
to have fun we have this sneaky move a6
which has a significant idea namely
trapping the Queen the best y can do
over here is Bishop to g5 but after rook
to b8 Bishop captures up 6 pawn captures
up 6 Queen to e7 and now the star move
Queen to c8 which indeed threatened
Bishop to c5 and trapping the white
sweetie
you
so that means white cannot play any
passive moves such as d3 in this
position the second option Bishop
captures D Phi is also a very bad choice
by the white camp and the simple
refutation goes as follows night to D
for attacking the Queen as well as
bishop and it looks like White has the
only saving resource namely Bishop
captures f7 but even after this black
and calmly played this winning move King
to e7 and now you can see the danger in
the right position white queen has been
attacked and the only way to support
this mission is go to the c-4 square but
I'm afraid that is not going to be
enough as Black has this little reply
Bishop to a5 not only threatening night
to see - but rook to see it is coming up
in a mix and all in all what is going to
lose a piece within the opening stage so
more or less if white come this far then
he has to take this pawn and challenge
the black setup well guess what
this is the case in the database with
more than 500 games and the highest elo
trapped in this variation is about 2600
so you can see the potential of this
line here black reveal his nasty idea
with this team attic amazing counter
jacking move Knight to d4 and I think
after this white is in a huge trouble
white queen is a
so as the nine so White Queen has to
safeguard the d5 square and the screen
check is always useless as it helps
black to develop bishop on d7 so
accordingly White has two choices number
one if he continued with Quinn to see
for supporting the D finite then we can
continue eight my captors defy White has
to capture with the bishop and now comes
very nice moon beef I once again
deflecting the Queen well same old
tactics comes into the picture after
Bishop captures epsilon black and calmly
play King to e7 and now in order to
safeguard the bishop White has the only
moon Quinn to defy but after this by
force black is winning with the
following forcing variation night to see
to check King to Devon Knight captures
even okay white can also grab a rock in
the corner but the end of the case when
we grab the bishop it is only black who
has come out with an extra piece and if
you run this position in any
professional engine it will tell you
that that night in the corner is coming
out so that means black has a clear
advantage in this variation
okay Dwight responds his force here what
has to capture this night and after that
my recommendation is you should continue
eight Queen captures f6 which raised the
question to the White Queen which spot
you are going to choose quaint to Devon
or Queen to d3 against both of this move
we are going to see some amazing line
from the black camp so let's see each
bite on
the first move I want to consider is
Quinn to d3 which is the second most
popular choice White Queen is
safeguarding the C 2 square and his idea
is if you continue with Bishop to a5
then Bishop to e4 is a very nice reply
now against Queen to d3 my suggestion is
you should continue with Bishop to d7
which has some nasty ideas namely Bishop
to be far as well as rook 2 CH and there
are plenty of chance where white can go
wrong and the game can be finished very
quickly for example if I become greedy
and continue with Bishop captures b7
then after rook to b8 Bishop to g2 and
now rook to c8 once again we are
threatening Knight 2 c2 which is
unstoppable and Bishop to b4 is also on
the card so that also hindered the
development of the white knight so this
line is right out of the equation
[Music]
the second movie 3 is not good
idol has black and continue with Bishop
to b5 and wife Queen has only pathetic
little scare namely Quinn to be one
after that we can continue with Bishop
to c6 and obtain a very good game but
the most interesting part is if why
choose to play Quinn to c3 which looks
very obvious stopping rook to c8 as well
as threatening pawn captures night
well guess watch this is a big time
blunder guys and before I move on I'd
like you to pause this video and find
out a decisive move which can force
immediate resignation
well I hope you find this winning blow
boom
so that queries trap right there and the
big point is if white capture this
Bishop then after night to see to we are
getting the Queen in a star last but not
least what happens if white continue
with Queen to Devon which is in fact the
most popular choice and here comes one
of the most powerful sequence in this
line starting with pressure up to a five
threatening night to see to Saudi three
is forced afterwards look to see it has
been played in almost all the games
which is in fact not my recommendation
as I have choose this rare but very
tricky mu fish up to be for check which
is not even played in a single game if
white continue with King to have fun
then black and simply castle on the King
side and the resulting position is quite
good for the black camp and I have
attached a sample line in the PG end but
who will play King F on when he can
continue with Bishop to d2 which I bet
white can play instantly has it covered
all the threat but guess what
nope you are not out of the trouble as
after Bishop captures d2 Queen captures
D to look to c8 threatening midnight to
c2 as well as rook to c2 so white
responses force white has to play hook
to c1 and after the rook exchange what
is more than happy as he is out of the
trouble with a healthy pawn up so what
can be the more neutral than this
and yes indeed at first sight this
position looks quite good for the white
camp except after blacks next reply
castle on the kingside why can more or
less resign the game on the spot
why well the simple answer is black is
threatening the moon look to see eight
and then penetration on C 2 square which
is now completely unavoidable if Bishop
captures b7 then Queen to b6 is very
strong reply and again as per the engine
the best reply is Knight to f3 but even
after this white is not out of the wound
as look to see it will happen on the
board and once the Queen goes to
anywhere let's say most accurate moves
Quinn to d1 we have this little check
which not only misplaced the white king
but on the top of everything the sting
in the tail
efore and white position is completely
busted
he has to take it and after that yup we
are going to continue it Bishop captures
e4 and no matter what hey were like
plays he had a completely lost position
now just to illustrate how quickly white
position can fallen apart I have reached
this position against a 2,200 rated
opponent and at this point he continued
with the obvious move b3 safeguarding
the b2 pawn but my answer will be the
same if he had played any other mousse
rook to d8 attacking the Queen Queen has
the only square left Quintus even and
now can you see the deciding blow yup
it's lovely deflection Queen to be to
hand my opponent resigned in the view of
Queen captures b2 rook check night even
and look to even deliver the knockout
punch that's it guys I hope you enjoy
and learn this amazing tricky line
against English opening remember at this
point continue with Knight to c6 allow
your opponent to capture on d5 and then
shock him with this decisive move Knight
to d4 and no matter however white
wriggles he get a completely losing
position well thank you for watching
this video feel free to like subscribe
and comment and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon
bye and take care
you